also das thema passt natürlich jetzt
einmal zum riesengroßen thema wird das
müssen und auch gegen den willen ihres
kommt auf der werks wir müssen uns
auch sehr gut weil also mich stört
wozu eigentlich ja eine gazprom stiftung
ganze fing an 2010 ich erinnere mich
vorgesetzten ja und zwar generell die
ehrlich machen und zwar immer genau an
sind nein ist eine gazprom stiftung und
dem punkt an dem es wirklich zu spät ist
gerne dass ich bin der professor und für
wahnsinnig so eine verlogene
alle keine ahnung hatten denn die wird
jetzt hat sie diese engen kontakte hat
und dass ich langsam nicht mehr hören
europa wissenschaften und ja die ersten
dann soll die frau kommt auf einmal muss
dass sie schon jetzt mal umsatz des
entschuldigungs kultur die wir jetzt
artikel geschrieben habe und gesagt habe
jahres und ich bin da ganz bei ihnen
sie die ahnung haben ich entschuldige
gerade in der politik erleben da geht es
dass geht böse aus weil immer wenn die
sie dann so ein bisschen
frau riekel ich finde auch die
sie ist ministerpräsident ja das ist ja
beiseitegewischt dann tauchten dokumente
deutschen was alleine mit den russen
konsequenzen die wir alle miteinander in
um die russland-politik und es geht
machen ja von rapallo über hitler stalin
auf die zeigen wie nahe doch diese
genau das erwarten wir von ihr mehr als
unserem berufsleben oder in unserem
bis heute ist es immer schief gegangen
natürlich auch um die spd aber auch um
beziehung zwischen ihrer regierung und
von all ihren vorgängig ich rede jetzt
privaten kreisen tragen müssen die
ja dh der fehler von gazprom war von
die cdu und plötzlich erklären alle
erwarten politiker recht selten und das
nicht von den vorgängen die kammer nicht
und putin war was ich also es gab
anfang an dass wir die polen nicht
auf
bin ich unglaublich und ausgeglichen vor
nachdem sie jahrelang so eine kungelei
gefragt haben dass wir den litauer dass
wirklich genügend kritiker und sie hat
allem das ehrlich machen dann denkt man
wir die ukraine nicht gefragt haben wir
betriebe am ort davon habe ich jetzt
ich nachts magnetisch paritätischer aber
immer auch und davor der politiker die
hätten ja auch eine pipeline bauen
artet das tut mit leid habe ich mich
bis zuletzt hat sie versucht daran
ganze zeit gelogen augen
können die irgendwie nicht von russland
festzuhalten
vorher habe ich mich nicht alle gemacht
nach deutschland geht sondern wo danach
geirrt
ich erwarte einfach von politik gern ja
und jetzt sagt sie naja unter den
so an diesem punkt an dem ich in die
und das soll es dann sein damit man bloß
über warschau nach was auch immer wer
ecke gedrängt wurde jetzt mache ich mich
egal ob frau oder mann erwarte ich
anscheinend fehlt vielen das zuschauen
dazwischen ist wo die auch gas bekommen
heutigen stand müssen stand hätte ich
keine persönlichen konsequenzen daraus
weil wir haben letztens auch ein
einfach konsequenzen wenn ich einen
dann wäre das ein europäisches dann war
leserbrief bekommen dass man wenn ein
mich hätte ich das vielleicht damals
zieht und da ist manuela schwesig leider
politiker wieder das wort ehrlich machen
ja wenn dann eher ja ich will ich will
anders entschieden und es ist auch so
fehler mache muss ich dazu stehen und
sagt man einen drink nehmen sollte als
ich will nur sagen wenn es ein
eine floskel ja weil ich finde in so
europäisches projekt gewesen wäre ja
ich muss auch die konsequenzen tragen
im spiel
unterscheidet sie sich überhaupt nicht
einem fall muss man eine persönliche
dann wäre das ein anderes projekt dann
von der politischen elite in wie sie so
und dass das ist in der politik
verantwortung übernehmen das ist ganz
würde das heute auch nicht dann würde
irgendwie nicht so verbreitet
deutschland nicht so unter druck stehen
wichtig auch unsere politiker sind ja
reagiert die politische elite gibt ja
jahrhundert freilich nur ein und uns
dass diese pipeline jetzt das zentrale
auch leitfiguren und in der in der
nur das zu was sie nicht mehr
genau weil also es kribbelt mir zu sagen
sozusagen jeden stand ist wenn es um
dass das natürlich ein phänomen ist was
verheimlichen kann und in dem fall hat
justiz gilt ja das prinzip nichtwissen
dieses thema geht ja das will ich nur
jetzt tatsächlich etwas älter ist ja ich
sagen insofern bin ich völlig entspannt
manuela schwesig hat ja
schützt nicht vor strafe ich kann nicht
erinnere mich auch noch an herrn zeitz
der regen zwei koffer irgendwie auf
ich habe das damals schon für einen
sondern einen schutzvertrag sowie boris
fehler gehalten dass wir das so
aktiv an diesem nord stream 2 mit gebaut
einem bahnsteig 1996 als damaliger
sozusagen und deutsch muss sich mäßig
becker habe ich auf die verträge
innenminister zurückgetreten ist weil er
machen klar hat die spd eine große
natürlich verantwortung als minister
geschaut dafür will ich nicht zu stellen
obwohl es viele
tradition leichten man kann auch noch
dafür übernommen hat das irgendwie zwei
ja so dass als kind nicht gelernt wann
polizeibeamte irgendwas nicht gemacht
mal daran erinnern egon bahr vena das
ich tennis spielen musste war wäre ich
kritiker gab die davon gewarnt haben es
haben das gehörte damals zum guten ton
waren damals die großen sozusagen
verstehe der sowjet republik ich finde
ich würde ihr völlig recht geben dass
habe hier auch so und deswegen finde ich
ist ja auch ein eine hochpolitische
dieser begriff von anstand dass man im
eigentlich weil ich bin ich finde die
es ja auch interessant dass heute
sachen unter umgehung der ukraine und
ehrenamt ausfüllt in bestem wissen und
verstehen was negatives ist eine putin
frau schwesig eigentlich uns eine
gewissen der republik ja und der
verstehe etwas schlechtes obwohl
vielen ost ländern ist diese gas
verstehen ist ja nicht was gutes wie
interessante figur und die hat ja auch
öffentlichen güter dieser republik dass
auch immer was ich nur sagen will ist an
das pannen gekommen ist also frau
super wahlen gewonnen und ich finde
spiegel musste ja gerade so aus dem amt
dieser pipeline war glaube ich die
pipeline hat uns natürlich noch enger an
jetzt müsste sie eigentlich zumindest
gedrängt werden so ein bisschen ja hat
erbsünde oder die originale sünde dass
also erst mal müssen sie alles
russland herangeführt und da gab es auch
sicher geklammert ohne ende aber das
offenlegen muss er zurücktreten
genug leute die gewarnt haben und die
wir sie nicht als wir das als deutsch
sollte
ich finde sie muss zumindest ein
russisches projekt praktisch ohne
dass ich ohnehin aus um so
europäisches konzept mitgemacht haben
frau schwesig hat wie auch glaube ich
rücktrittsangebot machen ich bin ja
frau merkel gesagt na ja das ist ein
die anderen partner nicht gefragt ja
jetzt viele nicht so brutal sein habe
die liste ist lang ja also eher haben
diese fake stiftung war auch schon
rein privatwirtschaftliches unternehmen
ich finde sie kann nicht einfach so
direkt
und das ist ehrlich gesagt eine
bergab wir haben comics wir haben heuer
ja das will ich nur sagen das war eine
weitermachen und die der rücktritt
verarschung des volkes wenn das ist es
mit der mautgebühr die sind alle noch am
anständige welt seien ja angefangen aber
nicht dass man immer hoch politisch und
abend der untersuchungsausschuss bei
dass zurücktreten soll das wird ja auch
herrn meier weiß man auch nicht ob der
dann kam doch erst viel später das ist
es gab auch eine große nähe von putins
schon von der cdu gefordert aber
durch weiß ich zeit habe sich das heißt
irgendwo irgend jetzt ist ja sowieso
nicht mehr minister gott sei dank ja
aber wir haben tatsächlich ganz große
buddies
das was ich thematisiere ist sozusagen
eigentlich nach meiner nach meiner these
skandale skandale in denen auch
die darin olver in der art und weise wie
millionen sozusagen volksvermögen wenn
zuvor schwesig oder zumindest zu ihrer
da übernimmt verantwortung muss sie
zurücktreten eine ganze menge andere
man es so formulieren möchte wo wir als
es designt war als nicht europäisches
regierung ja es wurde dann zum beispiel
politiker auch bringen soll sie dürfen
bürgerinnen darüber betrogen wurden ja
projekt designt und deswegen diese
mit mit ganz
diese klimaschutz stiftung gegründet
hier brutal sein sie dürfen fordert
sozusagen der fokus dass jetzt so eine
durchsichtigen machenschaften und die
deutsch russische geschichte anhand
aber andere leblich auch zurück drehte
dann wollte man was für das klima tun
sind alle noch am abend her und das
dieser pipeline festgemacht wird und
halte ich tatsächlich für ein richtiges
das war aber nur ein vorwand ist eine
das wohl
jetzt ist das der der zank gab sie
problem wenn anstatt sich nicht mehr
eine ganze menge und bevor wir jetzt
tarnorganisation weil damit sollte nord
unterbreche ja ungern habe ich möchte
lohnt oder in der politik sozusagen
natürlich auch noch alena gerber eine
auch sie raushauen es gab ja auch viele
nicht mehr das prinzip ist dass man
frage stellen zu dem thema dann ist das
stream zwei weiter finanziert werden und
die für diese pipeline mit höheren es
gerade steht das würde ich ihnen gerne
thema nämlich auch schon rum und zwar
geben damit nicht völlig dabei zu
gab eine forsa umfrage im mai 20 21
wir haben hier die ganze über
das sieht man schon daran also die also
entschuldigen gesprochen was uns nervt
gazprom hätte ich gerne den aspekt
haben sich noch 75 prozent der deutschen
dass man dann doch lieber zurücktritt
reingebracht ich wundere mich nur dass
mecklenburg vorpommern die regierung hat
gibt's denn irgendeine floskel die dich
für dich fertigstellung von notz dem 2
diese pipeline geschichte jetzt in
200.000 euro in diese stiftung
so richtig nervt im jahr 2022 bei den
dieser krieg auseinandersetzung auf
ausgesprochen dass sie hatte auch gegen
eingezahlt und gas 20 millionen also
politikern ja es im monat der politiker
den willen in der bevölkerung handeln
[Gelächter]